do you have apple watch a flock of birds
work together 1000 of animals
fly-in perfect singular
is not fascinating
becomes iphone remarkable is that these
birds
should not be able to do that if they also
how it handles your follow won leader
there reactions offers must simply  be to
do in set
scientists believe that these works
offline when few simple rules and
loud in every single turn to make
patterns solutions
was silent flyin perfect thing king of
alignment and able ceremony and error
tony
mixed him fixed and flexible
now becomes as this fierce white  and
inhabitants sometimes one way of
illustrating
becomes he love most import and
change that is not this in ways of
working to day we will this chain
faster and more complex
if not a new way of working ow that
great online my throne purpose that
takes  out chunks and that truly
empower people to make decisions vaster
we the issue is in order to get there
were told you willing to give up a few
years go by wo  rking again the bank that
won and barb oh no
digital transformation that won it there
offering to be simpler more into this
more add event
now i'm not sure how many of us see and
bang of die in site c limit fry second
straight wat  men the traditional banks
look like you see lots of people in
suits
13 elevator to go to care department
mark the first team with marketeers
engineers become engineers and set where
you see meetings' wit many people were
not dead sea side the
3-deurs de en  village in powerpoint parking
lots and there or endless hand' over
speedwing department's
getting any thing then can take for ever
they this brand now that in order to transform
you must have we in trial their time
to market by the west clique changing
the ways of working  aswell
is how to get some inspiration
wie the side it i don't have look the
camp that seem to be more now it is
like google
netflix spotify samples and remember how
we're walking the holset one of the
scampi's  in december 2014 and management
consultant and the team of thinkers
airport seems strangers in the comics
glue she lives where you beanbags and
hoodies and that so smart creative
semplice
so enthusiastic house york on video
next door and who i spectacular village
chart
putin stands the joost
strange flow  switch funny names like
spots en chapters and tries to explain
how they were list so who who try to
translate that chair one world
just how many people working for you in
the bands
good you report to the band
hoe die sites en your priorities
dit the page  you can imagine arcen pryce
who will be a surprise for who will be
stupid as the basic principles of
organizations and their wish there was in
the pants
nou about the course of the day
who did this better understanding of
their mobile bay pleases in the bar of
small
autonomous  teams der teems I want mini
startups that had product people and high
tea and teenagers in so a team so deco
design
image and test out that is with  customers
in the planet learn from rest in the
company
this is that not them the ovens between the
part mens who it all the skills not the
writer in the team close the end of the
day we had section iii factor becomes
who learns and wit starts  you like their
mobile
zoey were already taking of how to apply
some of the sadr toe bent
model of the host
i look with page is already d here's
a de reset
anyway liken model pref horn issue
before you become oh you willing to give
up  we wie willing to give up we did
not have and she made who was with
whom right
james is not only about embracing the you
it's about giving up on some of the old
aswell about that de past 5 years i've
worked witkamp is all over  the world to
change the ways of working and clearly
and free companies
hester own skeptics about why this is
not going to work for them out product
is mar complex of d-doen has de
Lekker cesartherapie doen of regulators just
won't allow this in arm  industry  ie
wat voor niet bang en Onze voor the
order kan kerk priest times were put
afterwords james was possible start
here wie complete i blew up the
outsiders between marketing product
channels and tight i3000 en blew again
reorganize en to 200 in fifty
multidisciplinary teams zo instead of
funx  people sitting griffith park people
and
engineer kind of engineers panicked
person and the engineer
we're all members or so a team you
can be a member of the team responsible
for account opening or for the mobile
banking app
etcetera and the go live know if that
new organization
some people and shaking it for the very
first time only to find out that they
get me sitting
two minutes away from each order immediately
were standing lashing emails and
set the switch port for the last ten
years  become a chc that the
lady is like chasing francis
with now they're having coffee together
and vvd has this product that people to
animal that edges race it to get input  t
van die engineer occupation
ryan extreme they can the site de test
wit customer simi deadly
no hen [ __ ] no power points nora take
just getting things done now getting
there is no easy and ass and turns out
being oh you willing to give up insect
sadly the  right fashion toe was
motors miss decisionmaking requires
multi-disciplinary teams
instead of decisions going up and down
the organization
wie want de team to the site we te doen
so we don't have all the skills and expertise for
that decision in the team and this brings
the [ __ ] performances
can be physically code qatar people
working in this building snufferd city
sorry van Dichtend country story of show
63 at the video conferencing and keep
wie inch urk consistency in the ww
doating sarcastic teams did not know
such a side or management matrixx
well
oil changes to  structure and process and
more precise biology with indiana iphone
that the most difficult it to change is
therefore behavior limit right want
straight to b  e one piece teams to be
fast flexible creative tasty mini
startup pff to be and power and
autonomous
we this means weekend level everyones
koeman thing de people what to do when to
do how to you know my care managers
what this our means that i champion something
leader
richard le software always form around something
builds everything
stepping out to take initiative
well who is who who also can not for
glass foil steams home in deventer
actions
lucas that would certainly let ok if
so who are not online and tony at the
same time just like a flock of birds in
an organizational setting
this requires new behaviors and will
teach you behavior
nu is giving up and santing altez wel
leaders has to make sure that everyone
in the organization is a line from the
oval purpose to my aunt die
protisten everywhere becomes your let
go
and pride of teams to make the right
decisions on how to get there
nou critique alignment requires open and
transparent communi  cation
which i know how they say that
information is the source of power
welsens managers sharing information
may feel as if you're giving up this
kind of shower and is not just managers
de teams die to communicate openly and
transparent
de teams typically work in
church prince and at the end of rvs
print dit be na fc den bosch session
to share the output of wat dan
transparently en fwd
each member of the team first an update
of what they are working on in de vitaly
now  all this transparency
candy uncomfortable for people picasso
dali
3 fast place to hide it anymore and
freezing wie doe is transparent for
everyone
so alignment is to easy and experiences
tony is still so on your site er
Woon excecutive set en Noord kamp three
likes to explain how  i used to be
a master of milestone tracking now to
day to know how things going
set vlogging it status free parts
the needs to walk down to the teams floor
student one  of their sessions
and a star of contention people what to
do i look for ways to help them
that is radical change for someone who
use baby
a master of smalst en tracking where
die neoprof
dit I put you on the city joni die
in luschen or  control
in reality many projects for throne over
time at over budget any way no life much
more transparency and can
correct earlier has not it
and middle managers not the changes will
travel
my on hand' overs and the powerpoint
so lessons for not from  middle managers
and in the lead role you were this idea of
thinkers and doers and blew therefore
father orders with well in star foil
managing other people
middle managers respect the public for
player coaches
so do me for the last ten years
juf-joyce.nl
order  people is to do with well that
respect the direction surselva can
clearly the narrow is not for everyone
and some great people love company
but by whom sets is a new culture
with les harley
a  war this is hard work
but something will become this the companion is detail
word wit they were you study folding
new product features a few home muscle
well dr losers and few weeks
and who holds the hand' overs and the red
tape the hall organization that comes my
vision and finally it job the host of
this company stray you just feel and your
energy it feels so few walking the
rules of the very large start now to be
fair use i go dat claim factory at
we prefer we this new model they
were  much better prepare to respond to
change the world is chain faster and
more complex
so who does not reboot a way of working
and the hardest part of that change is what
instructor
that process or more precise and is already or
right see here exact so sign charge
leaders of the role of box in the
organization and how a broadest james
wie oh has allegiance to the question
is whether you willing to give up
do you think
[Applause]
[Music]